demi lovato documents her latest tattoo  appointment hey you guys I'm Katie  Krauss and yeah dummy definitely got  some ink upgrades on Monday I'm excited  the 24 year old posted tons of snapchats  from her private session with celebrity  tattoo artist  bing-bang first check out this  side-by-side demi added a second rose to  her state tattoo on her wrist then the  former Disney star had a few feathers  and beads added to this dreamcatcher ink  the you make me beautiful message eNOS  still the same I wanted to have  something that made a statement  Demi's dog Batman was therefore part of  it and later she tweeted why is the  feeling of getting tattooed so addicting  you kind of want to keep people guessing  the new art comes just a few months  after Demi split from longtime boyfriend  Wilmer Valderrama who has since been  linked to his ex Minka Kelly  for all the latest on Demi keep checking  back to et online